[Music]
[Music]
well good morning and welcome to another
beautiful day we are going to japan
today i am so excited we got a very easy
morning um don't have to be to the
airport for a little while
it will uh it's nice i'm actually
looking forward to the flight
just being on a plane not having to
drive or wrangle kids or anything sounds
relaxing
we'll see we might do something fun with
the time before we get on the airplane
becca are you excited to go to japan i
am excited
aren't you presenting at a conference in
japan yes
are you ready no i haven't done it yet
i'm going to do my presentation on the
plane
we're going to distract you no i have to
get it done you get so distracted you
think you can sit next to all of this
and not get distracted
come on come on tom get your boots on
we're going to get breakfast
there are your boots put your boots on
boots boots boots boots
please they're right there
just put your feet in the
foods put your boots on boots
it's like this every time all right
tommy ready to check out go get some
breakfast yep
[Music]
check it out it's the beach
look at that that's the pacific ocean
keep going
yeah look at that
watch out don't go too far
well we've put our foot in the pacific
ocean tommy's got himself sandy and wet
and we found a shell for mommy i think
it's time to go to the airport what do
you think
all right tommy come on hurry up here
mommy we got you a shell
we're checked in we didn't die
i survived the rental car return process
i didn't get beaten up by the angry
angry shovel shuttle driver
ah so far so good
[Music]
i hope you guys are being good for
grandma and grandpa
[Music]
kiwi juice
use it
[Music]
wake up wake up wake up
okay
[Music]
all right guys we hit up the atm and
maxed out all of our cards japan is
still very much a cash society
and uh you can only get so much off your
card per day so
really we've got to get everything we
could so
we made it to osaka we've got to get
over to kyoto it's about an hour and
change away hopefully i'll figure out
where i need to go and how to buy my
tickets and get us on there in a
convenient and timely manner
and we're here
finally okay let's see here
oh yeah let's check this place out
okay so we got the game con gotta take
your shoes off
in the japanese house
look at this job
yep that's called the code tots that's
what that little table is called and
this is tatami mat all right let's turn
the ac on
i hit that button
we set it to 27. see down those are
futons yeah those are for beds
here let me show you the japanese
bathroom it's different
[Music]
yeah so check it out guys we got a
modern japanese toilet here
it comes with a control panel
it's the bidet feature there's the
high-powered butt cleaning
and this is sets the temperature so if
you want warm water to clean your butt
and here's the
the kitchen
little tiny japanese kitchen these are
doors made out of paper
see
well we got ourselves settled in i'm
going to go out and get some food for
the family it's raining so i'm going to
pop open our umbrellas because every
japanese house has an umbrella stand i
like it
[Music]
all right got some
stuff to drink some treats for the
morning
and a little dessert
mossberg it's the mcdonald's in japan so
they have mcdonald's here too
i got some yukimi
which is ice cream wrapped in glutinous
rice one of our favorites
i've got
two cold papri sweats
there you go guys that's a moss burger
right there it's like barbecue sauce
mayonnaise a veggie patty and
some tomato
or you can get the pork cutlet burger
which is deep fried pork cutlet with
shredded cabbage
nice
it has been a long couple days but we
are here in japan
good night everybody
me and tommy are all jacked up we woke
up at five in the morning
and uh we just can't sleep but mama can
so we're gonna go out and explore the
city a little bit and get something to
eat what do you say yeah i'll take
soda with marbles real quick
no no it's friendly
hey tom you see what that is
that's a turntable you park your car on
it and it spins around and lets you
turn around look at this tom whoa
it's a little
shrine check out this is a japanese
parking lot you pull in there and the
little thing flips up so you can't back
out then you pay and then let your car
go
that's that's how they do parking meters
in
japan let's go to the supermarket
yeah does that feel good
you want a really good apple yeah
see look at that that's
that's five dollars that's five dollars
and fifty cents for two apples
yeah we don't need to buy tons of them
oh i remember these these are little
peanut sandwiches i love these
how about this you want
you want a strawberry sandwich check
this out
peanut butter
almost six dollars look right here
though
is it marbles yeah right here
okay should we get one for you yeah is
there a marble in it there are there is
this is one that tommy's been wanting to
try forever
open this up
and you get this little plunger here
take the plunger out
squeak
and it pushes this marble that's
blocking the hole like a cork pushes it
down into the bottle
and then there's this marble
sitting in there see how you can
see this marble
marble floating around done can we
probably try to get the marble out
absolutely traditional original flavor
ramune tastes a little bit like a sprite
but different
definitely different but that's the
closest thing to compared to
are you enjoying that yeah but guys if
you get caught to the marbles you get to
keep them in countdown
what is it the peanut butter sandwich
[Music]
it's bread and peanut butter eat it
yeah japanese peanut butter is sweeter
and lighter
it's more like a
peanut butter flavored cake frosting
we're gonna walk back and we're gonna go
to the train station and get some food
for mama
you want to ride on my shoulders
oh tommy back of my head is wet and they
call me ramen ahead
this is so nostalgic for me
i lived in southern japan for two years
as a missionary for the mormon church
and i've been back to visit one time
with becca
it's my first trip to honshu the main
island of japan
but oh
brings back so many memories one of the
best times of my life
it's even my best time in my life
because i got ramen
and i got marble inside it's fun walking
by everyone's houses you see lots of
interesting things and most of the
houses here have a fire bucket full of
water on the front porch yeah see
there's their fire bucket there's their
fire bucket
there's the fire bucket another fire
bucket fire bucket
and a statue of a priest look at that i
have no idea what type of car that is
copen huh never seen that kind of car
before this is a little neighborhood
shrine people will burn incense there
and put little offerings there
flowers or sake or little treats and
then they ring the bell and say a prayer
hey look it's a dabbing cat
see tommy this is what mama wants
to put there okay don't drop it don't
drop it yeah we get one for you
i love being so broken should we get one
of these
careful there you go
do you know how to say good morning
[Music]
yes there's konichiwas hello
and ohio is good morning
[Music]
your vocabulary is growing
it is a croquette it's like a deep fried
pastry usually with some sort of meat or
curry filling or something so i didn't
read the carefully what was in there so
oh it looks like it's got a curried egg
inside
so we drank the ramen a and tommy wants
the marble out so
go and unscrew that
and then give it a good squeeze pop
and
there you go
there's the barrel you want that yeah
two marbles
well i'm feeling a little grimy after
that to my whole walk
and so i'm gonna take a bath but check
this out this is a japanese bath
the tubs are not for cleaning they're
for soaking and relaxing
don't ever clean yourself in the tub
that's considered gross
take the shower you sit on the stool
and use a little bucket
dump it over and you wash here in the
shower area and then if you want to take
a bath you soak in the tub after you've
cleaned yourself
a little basic japanese etiquette right
there well guys after breakfast and one
of the most luxurious showers of my life
the family and i are going to go hit the
church
which will be interesting
because
two out of the three members of this
household don't speak japanese that well
so
what's gonna be interesting
tell me is this better than walking
all right guys we're here at church uh
i'll see you in a little bit well that
was fun did you have a good time having
a great time you know i like going to
church other places yeah it's absolutely
a blast you're going to be in lots of so
many nice people what do you got there
in your hand somebody gave me some sushi
someone gave you a sushi keychain that's
awesome
oh look persimmon tree i love these
things
[Music]
it's a lovely day
and it's not raining on us in your face
weather report tommy should we get mommy
a drink
all right tommy we get that
so this is pocari sueto
it's your ion supply drink
but what does it taste like it tastes
like nothing else
it's good it's a subtle flavor it's not
a strong maybe like if you took lemon
gatorade and watered it down
but different yeah very different
good you like it yeah check it out
they've got a parking lot just for
bicycles and it's two stories
okay tommy you want to go on a train
let's do it put it in there yeah there
you go babe
check it out they've got the women-only
line to avoid
sexual harassment while standing in line
this is one of my favorite foods in
japan it's called a croquette
it's like mashed potatoes with
vegetables and meat in it it's deep
fried
it's a ball of mashed potatoes
you dip it in this sweet soy sauce it's
so good and this is what becca got it's
a karage or a deep fried chicken and it
is so tender and good
well we enjoyed a lovely lunch but uh
becca isn't just here for pleasure she's
here for a work conference so we're
gonna run over to the convention center
and uh just set up her booth and
help her out real quick there we go
icots 2018 the international conference
on teaching statistics and my sexy honey
bunny right here
he's a statistician
what's the odds of that
well i got myself changed into some
comfy clothes and we're about to go out
sightseeing but i was thumbing through
the home's instruction manual and i saw
this great tutorial on how to use a
potty
that's awesome you know they didn't just
do that it's been a problem well i'm
excited to go out on a walk with my
lovely wife but i had a minute i'm
exhausted
i've been up since like 4 45 and
walked several miles
but it's it's lovely the weather's
perfect what's your favorite thing about
japan so far
i like to drink
today that has marbles
nice
look at that tom
yeah this is the toji temple
you see him
there looks like there's an upper 30s
cart just right up there looking for
handouts
i would go fishing for him if i didn't
think he would land me in jail all right
guys we're gonna go hit you at a ramen
shop here we're here at a ramen shop
we're gonna get some croquettes and
joseph some ramen and uh hopefully tommy
won't pass out
no too late he's passed out all right we
got some gyoza some kroger
and
oh tommy zonked out he's so tired he
fell out of his chair and hit his head
and then uh
when we woke him up he dropped his soda
glass and
broke it all over the place
poor guys exhausted let's get him to bed
it's been a fun day but it's getting
dark and it gets dark really early here
at like 7 30 and the sun comes up like 4
30 so we wake up when the sun comes up
so we gotta go down when the sun goes
down or we're just gonna be trash this
trip so
i'm gonna call it
i'm gonna go to bed at like 8 30.
i need some sleep well welcome to
another beautiful day and this is where
our trip here in japan really gets
started me and tommy got a lot of things
we want to do but first uh we're gonna
get mama some food
and uh maybe go get a bicycle or
something what do you say
one thing we're gonna do here is we're
gonna rent a bike and so i got one with
a car seat on the back so tommy can hang
with me
all right oh you got a belt
juice all right go for it it looks
delicious thank you tell me what you
think of it
yes good oh i like your strawberry one
that's right strawberry
one is the best
[Music]
all right this is super nostalgic for me
when i lived in japan i rode bicycles
everywhere
yeah it's a boat
all right guys we're just riding our
bikes i see a shimano sign and a bunch
of pictures of fish it's a fishing store
check it out that's a eel trap right
there
oh this place is awesome
this nice lady here is telling me that
the river has uh catfish in it and so
she's
sold me some stuff for catfish and i'm
gonna get myself a license and uh we're
gonna see what happens so check it out
this is called gyotaku
take and put a little ink on the fish
you catch you press it down on the paper
and then the way of preserving your fish
is kind of like taxidermy
all right tommy it's hot let's get some
stuff in the drink get some ice cream
that's pineapple you want to try that
yeah hold on to that there you go that's
like ice cream cotton candy
it's a watermelon cone
you like that oh yeah it's actually
great
watermelon flavored popsicle with
chocolate seeds
oh look at this fishing shop tom
this is pretty cool
check this out we got a big old fishing
store here this is this is what we're
looking for
[Music]
bud
[Music]
these are all squid lures
look at the size of these floats look at
these it's bigger than tommy
look at this float section this is
amazing yeah look at that
oh rod cases
oh i love these two these are the daiwa
life vests
oh i love these
tackle boxes
oh look at that has got to be expensive
lure
these are the telescopic landing nets
these are awesome
take these out these little cages you
put bait in
and you use them for chumming
so you throw that out there and the chum
comes out and you catch the fish
all right let's go
well me and tommy have been all over
kyoto on our bicycle but my bum's sore
i'm a little sunburned a little tired so
i'm gonna go check out a kendo supply
store on the way other side of kyoto
and uh we're gonna get a taxi here a
little bit to do that
no booster seat riding like a big boy
what do you think tom is that cool
samurai armor and that's the samurai
sword
come on inside bud
put the sandals on
you got the kindle stuff
yeah
yeah isn't that cool
yeah that's 390 dollars cool that's how
cool that is
ah hello
gotta kendall fight me
[Laughter]
are you attacking me
are you taking ah
hey
tommy do you want to go up to the top
yeah some more moving stairs yeah we're
getting up pretty high aren't we
these escalators are just like crazy
tall tommy all right 11 stories of
escalators later i think we're at the
roof
you want to go up to the very roof tom
oh there you go fun little view
i can see a train from up here wow this
is there we go that's the view from up
the top of the kyoto station right there
kind of cool all right tommy you want to
get a peach smoothie
okay we'll get a peach smoothie
getting some shish kebab for lunch tommy
wants some meat
all right we're gonna grab some uh
breakfast for tomorrow we're going
fishing tomorrow so we need to have uh
some lunches and breakfast ready to go
and then we're gonna head home and um
[Music]
yeah all right i am glad to be home
let's let's eat some food
unload our bags then we'll go to another
fishing store take this off now pull
that out
pull that out
now so you put that on
and then you slip this part on
is that mine this one is yours yes
okay
[Music]
this is so cool nathan's gonna love this
we got some sunscreen dropped off our
stuff got a belly full of food let's go
try another fishing store
look at that tom those are for
sharpening knives oh my goodness that's
beautiful
wow
oh that's beautiful
wow
[Music]
hey tom what do you think
carp
but i think it's a picaroon fish bonker
that is awesome i'm gonna give myself a
nice telescoping rod and a rod case to
bring it back on the airplane with all
right so we're buying a couple rods a
few reels another rod bag
i have an addiction
i admit that
crews in kyoto and a three-gear mama
chatty with my ombre in the back seat
and fishing gear across my back
so dreams are made up people
[Music]
here why don't you show mommy your
samurai sword oh it has some good it has
some give too it's not a solid piece of
wood
okay stop attacking mommy
okay
come on daddy
let's do that
let's do it hey guys we're here at this
yakiniku place and it's a buffet and
we're supposed to select what we want
off this menu
unfortunately my ability to read
kanji or the chinese characters
and so i
hope
i ordered
beef but uh we'll see well tommy's
falling asleep again but the food is
great and
we're having a good time
[Music]
well that tommy boy is getting heavy but
he's the bed
and i'm going to be right behind him but
uh tomorrow i was supposed to go fishing
with a guide
but i got word that the flooding that
they've been having around here has
affected the water levels and they're
they're rescheduling or something it's a
little up in the air right now but uh
yeah we'll just kind of play it by ear
and see what happens tomorrow but uh i
am full of meat and
tired and i'm just gonna go take a
shower in that awesome awesome bathroom
and go to bed so i'll see you guys
tomorrow
if you like this video don't forget to
check out part four of our 2018 world
tour where we continue to rock it in
japan
sightseeing fishing and tommy even gets
bitten by an owl but anyway if you guys
want to see this click the link below
we've got tons of great videos and if
you want to see the fishing videos check
out my other channel the catfish and
carp channel